[موسيقى]
الصين تكشف عوره بريطانيا وتذيع اسرارها
للعلن واللي ما يشتري يتفرج كما يقولها
المصريون وفي تحدي خطيرا لامن تايوان
المقاتله الصينيه تتلاعب بالمقاتلات
الامريكيه في اجواء تايوان وواشنطن تتواعد
فما الذي يجري وموسكت توجه رساله نوويه من
المحيط الهادئ
من خسائر فادحه دون اي نتائج تذكر بالهجوم
الاوكراني والمعارك تشتعل بين الروس
والاوكران وعدد كبير من الضحايا للطرفين
وصياد العقوبات الامريكيه ينزل على بوتين
ولكن الغرب هو من يتالم والسعوديه تصدم
اسرائيل بخطوه جديده وامريكا تشكر قطر
والجزائر تقترب من دخول خط كوارث المغرب
العربي
ارباك اوكراني كل ما اقترب الشتاء ارتفعت
الاصوات التي تؤكد في هجومها المضاد وان
القادم لن يكون اسهل مما مضى فيما يحاول
زلل تغطيه الخسائر بتصريحات الروتينيه
ولكن هذه المره رفع العيار قليلا ليخرج
الرئيس الاوكراني
ويؤكد بنبره حاده ان قوات بلاده لن تترخى
في مواجهتها هجمات الغزوه وان كل الوسائل
متاحه للدفاع عن ارض اوكرانيا بحسب تعبيره
هل هناك وسائل اخرى لم يستخدمها الاوكران
بعد لكنها رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني الاسبق
نيجولاي ازارووف يقول عكس ما يقوله
زلميسكي حيث اكد ازاروبا القوات
الاوكرانيه فقدت امكانياتها الهجوميه
بالكامل وانتقلت الان من موقع الهجوم
المضاد الفاشل الى الدفاع ياتي الدور على
صاحب الاقمار الصناعيه ونقصد رجل الاعمال
الامريكي الى ماسك والذي قال ان
قوتكبدت خسائر فادحه في الارواح دون اي
نتائج لهجومها هذا مضيفا تكبدوا الكثير من
القتلى مقابل نتيجه لا تذكر برايكم هل
يتحدث ماسك عن اطلاع ومراقبه للحرب من
الفضاء ام ان لديه صلات اخرى في الداخل
الاوكراني لتستمر التوترات في اوكرانيا
لكن هذه المره بسبب العجز الاقتصادي حيث
اعلنت رئيسه لجنه الميزانيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني رادار
بقيمه 43 مليار دولار من الدول الغربيه في
عام 2024
لتغطيه عجز ميزانيتها وهو طلب رسمي بطريقه
ملتويه لاموال الغرب فهل تتم الاستجابه
لهذا الطلب ومن احدث التوترات الى معارك
البارود وضجيج الاسلحه هنا اعلنت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه تدمير 12 هدفا جويا
للجيش الروسي من بينها 60 من طراز شاهد
ايرانيه الصنع مما زعمت الهيئه بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت من القضايا على 500 من
عناصر الجيش الروسي خلال يوم وهي المره
الاولى التي ننقل بها عددا كهذا في
الخسائر الروسيه ولكن العهده على المصدر
قناه هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الدفاعات
الجويه دمرت خلال ساعات الاربع والعشرين
الماضيه 12 هدفا جويا روسيا من بينها ست
مسيرات من طراز شاهد ايرانيه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من القضاء على
نحو
530 من عناصر الجيش الروسي
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدميرا
مسيرتين اوكرانيتين فوق الجزء الجنوبي
الغربي من شبه جزيره القرم واحباط محاوله
من نظام كييف لتنفيذ هجوم ارهابي لتعود
اوكرانيا وتعلن ان قواتها استعاده السيطره
على بلده التي تكتسي اهميه استراتيجيه
جنوب هذا وكان الجيش الروسي
[موسيقى]
اليكم المصدر من جانب اخر اعلنت اوكرانيا
ان قوتها استعادت السيطره على بلده
كليشتيف كا التي تكتسي اهميه استراتيجيه
جنوب وكان الجيش الروسي نفا سحاب قواته من
بلدتي اندريه
في الجبهه الشرقيه لياتي الرد من وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بالاعلان عن توجيه ضربه
صاروخيه مكثفه استهدفت مستودعات لصوا
البريطانيه وكذلك مخزن ذخيره تحتوي على
اليورانيوم المنظم في اوكرانيا فهيالها من
ضربه قويه نزلت كالصاعقه على القوات
الاوكرانيه وعلى ذات السياق اشارت
اوكرانيا الى ان روسيا اطلقت 24 مسيره على
منطقه
ثماني عشره مسيره وسبعه عشر صاروخ كروز
وفق البيان الاوكراني ومن الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا الى المعارك ضد الغرب فقد مدد
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير صلاحيه مرسوم صدر
عام 2014 بشان تدابير الرد على العقوبات
المناهضه لروسيا والتي تنطوي على حظر
استيراد مواد غذائيه من بعض الدول
الاجنبيه لعام 2024
وبين هذا وذاك وجهت روسيا رساله نوويه
مباشره للدول الغربيه حين نقلت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه لقطات من مناورات البحريه
الرو في شمال المحيط الهادئ وذلك بمشاركه
غواصه تومسك الصاروخيه النبويه وطرت
فارياج الصاروخي التنين ينفث لهبا هو
التنين الصيني يعلنها كالعاده غير وسيله
للدفاع هي الهجوم لينشغل العدو بنفسه قبل
ان يسبب المشاكل لاصحاب العيون الضيقه
وهنا يذكر تقرير حكومي بريطاني ان الصين
تستهدف موظفي الخدمه المدنيه والعسكريين
بعروض عمل مربحه ضمن حمله تجسس واسعه اذ
خلص التقرير الى نتائج تدعن على اساسها
المملكه الصين باختراقات القطاع الاقتصادي
في بريطانيا كما حضرت من معاهد كونفوشيس
الصينيه في زعزعه امن المملكه المتحده
لتتجه البوصله الصينيه نحو تايوان موجهه
اخطر تحدي تعيشه الجزيره باكبر عدد من
الطائرات الصينيه الحربيه التي تقترب من
فقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التايواني انها
رصدت تحليق 130 طائرات حربيه صينيه حول
الجزيره خلال 24 ساعه وكانت الوزاره اعلنت
النبكيين تجري مناورات بعيده المدى
وتدريبات مشيره الى انها تراقب الوضع عن
كثب فاتمتلك تايوان ما يجعلها تصمد امام
التنين الاحمر الصيني اما في واشنطن فقال
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
جنرال
سترتكب ما وصفه بخطا استراتيجي فادحه اذا
شنت هجوما عسكريا على جزيره تايوان واضاف
ميلي في حديث لشبكه الاخباريه الامريكيه
ان بلا دوله تسعى لصراع مع بكين لكنها
تستطيع صدامها على الجزيره في حال حدوثه
الاحداث والتطورات
افادت وسائل اعلام عبريه ان السعوديه صدمت
اسرائيل بوقت مباحثات تطبيع العلاقات التي
يقودها الجانب الامريكي منذ مده واشارت
مصادر امريكيه مطلعه الى ان المملكه ادخلت
الفلسطينيين للمباحثات مع الجانب الامريكي
بشكل ذكي حتى يكون لها القرار في شكل
الاتفاق مع الطرف الاسرائيلي وموعده
وبالتالي ترسيم حدود دولتهم المستقله دون
تدخل من الخارج بعد وصول خمسه امريكيين
افرجت عنهم ايران الى الدوحه مقابل
التحرير ارصده طيران المجمده والسفير
الامريكي بقطر قول نشكر قطر على مساعدتنا
في الافراج عن الامريكيين المحتجزين
الخمسه وهذا مثال على قيادتها الاقليميه
ومشاركتها العالميه اعلن مركز البحث في
علم الفلك والفيزياء الفلكيه والجوفيزيائي
في الجزائر عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه جنوبيه
الجزائر العاصمه وسجل مركز البحث في علم
الفلك والفيزياء الفلكيه والجوفيزياء عند
الساعه الثانيه عشره 55 دقيقه هزه ارضيه
بلغت شدتها 3 درجات فاصله واحد على مقياس
ريختر بولايه المسيله نتمنى ان تكون هذه
الهزه هي اقوى ما يحدث للجزائريين ولا
يتكرر ما حدث في المغرب وليبيا لدى الجاره
الجزائر
[موسيقى]